oh damn aber ein Pie- nice
huge
so jetzt sollte es eigentlich gleich wieder losgehen
ah jetzt
jetzt sieht man aber
sieht man jetzt was?
ok ok alles klar
ok gut
alles klar
so und jetzt haben wir jetzt
1080p leute
checkt mal ab blitz
virid ist einfach überlebt
so ich check mal kurz ob wir jetzt
1080p haben
wieder wieder toll
toll auf twitch hier gerade
was ist das denn?
mensch twitch regt mich doch nicht so auf
funktioniert doch einfach
kann doch nicht sein
boah wie mich das nervt ey
was ist denn das problem ich hab mir
genau den gleichen settings letztens auch
schon gestreamt mit exakt
den gleichen settings
wie oft soll ich den kram jetzt noch
neu starten bis es funktioniert